y
[Música]
bienvenidos a este avance informativo en
france 24 iniciamos en perú el jurado
nacional de elecciones suspendió al
magistrado y luís arce luego de que ayer
renunciara al órgano electoral la
decisión de darse se produjo cuando el
jurado estaba revisando las
impugnaciones de votos solicitadas por
la candidata keiko fujimori en unos
comicios en los que el aspirante de
izquierda pedro castillo tiene una
estrecha ventaja más temprano desde lima
nuestro corresponsal francisco zacarías
nos amplia la renuncia del magistrado
luis arse al jurado nacional de
elecciones dejó cinco euros al tribunal
electoral en circunstancias en que
delibere las impugnaciones presentadas
por keiko fujimori para las elecciones
del 6 de junio parce a pesar de estar
impedido por ley y renunciar dimitió al
cargo y con esto retrasa aún más la
proclamación de pedro casi o como
presidente el magistrado cuestionó la
labor del organismo electoral y afirmó
que con su alejamiento evita que sus
votos sean utilizados en lo que él llama
falsas deliberaciones constitucionales
representantes de pedro castillo vieron
con suspicacia la dimisión de arce
cuando el tribunal electoral
rechazado en las 10 primeras peticiones
en realidad presentadas por keiko
fujimori en esa línea acusaron al
fujimorismo de promover un intento de
golpe de estado por su parte a los
partidarios de keiko fujimori rechazaron
las acusaciones y solicitaron una
auditoría internacional a los comicios
del 6 de junio mientras tanto la
organización de los estados americanos
así como la unión europea reafirman que
el proceso electoral peruano ha sido
libre y democrático al menos un muerto y
99 desaparecidos deja el colapso parcial
de un edificio en soft side de 24
kilómetros al norte de miami los equipos
de búsqueda informaron que al menos 102
personas que se encontraban bajo los
escombros fueron rescatadas o salieron
por su cuenta de las ruinas el edificio
de 12 pisos fue construido en 1981 las
causas del desplome aún no han sido
aclaradas
los ingenieros analizando la situación
para tratar de determinar qué sucedió y
cuál fue el problema y muy probablemente
no vamos a tener esas respuestas de
inmediato pero sé que trabajarán
diligentemente para poder
hacer esto es un día trágico de honduras
inauguró su embajada en jerusalén
previamente ubicada entre la vid
siguiendo los pasos de países como eeuu
guatemala y kosovo
el presidente de hondureño juan orlando
hernández calificó a jerusalén como la
eterna capital de israel algo que la
autoridad nacional palestina tildó de
flagrante violación del derecho
internacional
la gran mayoría de países europeos se
opuso a la ley aprobada en hungría que
prohíbe hablar de homosexualidad en los
colegios y en los medios de comunicación
tras considerar que es un retroceso para
los derechos de la comunidad lgbt en la
cumbre de este jueves en bruselas
también se discuten la migración y la
respuesta a la pandemia además de la
posibilidad de una reunión entre la
unión europea y rusia- una propuesta
hecha por francia y alemania
en canadá las tumbas sin identificar de
hasta 751 personas fueron halladas en lo
que en su momento fue una escuela
residencial católica para niños
indígenas
el hallazgo ocurre semanas después de
que fueran encontradas 215 tumbas en la
provincia de british columbia muchas de
ellas de menores nativos la comisión de
la verdad y reconciliación de canadá
advirtió que este sistema de escuelas
que operó por casi dos siglos era
equivalente a un genocidio cultural el
primer ministro de los 52 dijo que el
país necesita reconocer su historia
racista
llegamos hacia el final del avance y
regresamos en unos momentos